[Music]
as we move forward as scientists as
biologists
the old adage is true
a picture is worth a thousand
words
so what is
that image that graph that graphic or
even that
imagery um that that really gets to the
core of your idea um it almost gets to
advertising you want that image to stick
in your listeners minds um that both
lets them understand the undeniably
complex concept that you're trying to
convey but also makes it memorable
and developing that skill to come up
with that picture that is truly worth a
thousand words is going to be
the skill that we will all need
going into the future creativity plays a
role in my life
pretty much every single day by
reminding me not to stop just because
i've reached a setback like
hitting a wall as you're moving towards
a goal doesn't have to be the end for
that goal
to me it just means that the path to
success isn't going to be quite as
straightforward as i originally thought
like the way around that wall may
require me to climb over it or tunnel
under it or or maybe even dig straight
through it but if i'm creative enough i
can probably find a way to get to the
other side and this plays out for me in
the lab literally every single day it
feels a tenacity that can see you
through things like graduate school if
you ever choose to go that route
[Music]